[Music]
welcome to your biscuits I'm link and
I'm Rhett this week at our respective
tables of varying lighting in our own
homes we're gonna be talking about
relational dynamics during quarantine
I'm telling you man we but we're gonna
open a can of well not a can of
whoop-ass I'm talking about it this is
like what's it a can of worms that's
what I was thinking about how many cans
are they listen there's Waldo for the
can of whoop-ass you want me to come
over and whoop your ass I need to whoop
somebody's ass right I'd love to see you
come over here try talking about
relational dynamics there's a couple of
times I just I'm just walking around my
house and my kids and it's turned from
like an affectionate hug into like how
hard can I squeeze them before they
start to panic I don't know if that's a
good thing to admit but I mean it's not
like Lando's my wife was always bring
the amazing what are you whispering
about if she's gonna talk tell her to
speak up yeah see this is ash laughs see
this is it Shepherds on the show call
with his teacher and I'm doing this
there's tension in the air man I mean
that's what quarantine is all about is
about teaching in the air it's there's
wool pants there's worms and there's
what else I mean is there an is there
another can I've opened candies of
knowledge for people before bright man
you know what it's expired I'm gonna
open a cannon knowledge on you that's
not one nope we're still at two that's
not well I thought you know beans but
that's that's all yet all too literal
yeah sometimes I do go to cans of beans
I have been trying to do dry beans but
on my own but I do have cans as a backup
i interesting thing about cans of beans
is that I find myself trying to get my
beans to taste as good as the canned
beans
right seems that that that is the goal
of every bean recipe is just a taste as
good as canned beans because those
people at Bush's man they figured it out
dude perfect is selling their own beans
when you found out about that did it
make you mad yeah it was like a it was
like a trick shot to the heart it made
me a little mad I was like hold on we
should be selling beans does this mean
we can't sell beans I think we should
undercut dude perfect
we should we what's it called when
you're like when you backend when
someone goes up for a rebound and you
back into them and then they fall let's
use their terminology that's boxing out
let's box them out on their own beans
let's buy their beans and undercook oh
okay you're you're using you've got like
three analogies going now I don't see I
don't think so I have tension and now
look at me I'm taking it out on dude
perfect the people on the internet that
are like the the the ones that invite
the least amount of ridicule all of a
sudden I'm picking a fight with dude
perfect what this is what's happening I
mean I've been looking forward to this
conversation cuz rep I look forward to
our our your biscuit every week cuz it's
it yeah it's one of a handful of
lifelines that I have and your biscuit
ear listening if you feel like this show
is a lifeline in this quarantine don't
put so much pressure on us but I'm glad
to hear it but I'm trying to figure out
there's another part of me that I think
he could be therapeutic to get this out
but I got there's some stuff in this
past week a little bit more that I don't
know as we start to talk about
relational dynamics in my home I just
might I guess I'm gonna go there I think
I think it would be I'd like to get your
I'd like to get I like to verbally
process I'm gonna say we're gonna do a
lurch no I think we're both gonna go
there no you're okay Anna can elicit
your cans that's just another name for a
big headphones I
I think we're both gonna go there I
think this is about you know this is a
little
commiseration both with each other but
also with the mythical beasts and it's
interesting because I see people talk
about like oh it was cool when you guys
talked about movies because it was
light-hearted him or when you talked
about hobbies during quarantine it was
light-hearted and I needed that and I'm
not saying this is not gonna be
light-hearted but we're gonna we're all
processing together yeah and so it's
gonna be what its gonna be whatever kind
of cans need to be opened up whoop-ass
knowledge beans here what was the other
one ear cants cans of listen cans of
listening but even before that worms
worms yeah yeah yeah yeah one of the
originals one of the original cans yeah
that's right now I'm gonna spray those
cans down and then we're gonna wipe
those cans down and then we're gonna
move them to a disinfected area and then
we're gonna proceed to open them one by
one before we get into talking about
well actually I mean this is a
relational dynamic I mean I think I want
to start by talking about my relational
dynamic with the most important member
of my family and that is Barbara of
course and our our relational dynamic
has changed during this time Barbara is
first of all I think Barbara is confused
that I'm around so much yeah and I think
that I've lost a little of my spark for
her oh I mean one of the things that one
of the things that I've noticed is that
I mean I hate to admit this but it's
very true my wife is the favorite of
Barbara in fact Barbara loves my wife so
much that she will do the things that
she's doing right now is you know how I
I get down on the floor every single
morning to do my back stretching routine
of course yes and traditionally that has
been Barbara's cue to get down
on top of she doesn't do it where she
does well now what she does is when I
get on the ground now Barbara sleeps at
the foot of the bed most of the most
nights barbarac stands up looks at me
and then goes and starts licking Jesse's
face so it's like oh now I need to go
have human contact but why jump down
there with that bearded maniac when I
could kiss this clean face woman and
have you talked about what was happening
I've talked to Barbara about it yeah
well I begin to beg I have a thing that
I do I start going and what does she do
oh she looks at me and then she begins
to nestle into Jesse even more oh she's
a friendly there she is right there she
just came over here to look she's like
yeah you were spotted me right now you
want some love you can't have any Jay
come here Jay I'm having a similar thing
with Jade because and if you if you
watched our mythical society car vlog we
do those once a month one well and
before all this happened I shared that
like Jade is not sleeping in the bed
with me anymore because she would get up
in the middle of the night to drink
water and she would only do it if she
had an escort which would be me but it
would wake up me and Christie so and
sometimes she would need to go to the
bathroom so we started crating her in
order to retrain her to go all night
without food or water or peeing and then
just do it in the morning Jade but then
over this break she started sleeping
it's not in the crate but with Lincoln
you know I'm really starting to feel
jealous because we're letting the kids
sleep in later so like it's 10:20 right
now Lincoln got up like 20 minutes ago
which meant Jade didn't get up until 20
minutes ago I don't know if she's peeing
in his bed or what he just took her out
but so like all that quality time I used
to have on my dog I really miss Jade now
kind of want
put her back in my bed but now Lincoln
is starting to say that he's the
favorite the dynamics are changing here
even with the dolls
I think it's representative of of larger
things that are happening but one of the
concerning things that's happening with
Barbara is uh of course you know Barbara
is a small bushy dog I don't know if
that's the correct term technical term
but you know she's got a lot of hair
except where she needs to be groomed and
she's got some I don't remember what she
is but she's a mud but she's got
something in her that she would her hair
would grow very very long like even like
down toward the floor
whoa but she's got like some poodle in
her so it's curly so I don't know what
would happen but it would throw out and
would be very big so she gets regularly
groomed but of course nothing like that
I mean regular grooming is not happening
for me
as you can see and also for anyone in
this house including Barbara now I don't
care me too and I don't care that she's
got dreadlocks and there's other things
happening in her hair and it's like I
was just like let it run let's let it
ride you know what I'm saying and we'll
fix this at the end of this gives us
something to look forward to but Jesse
wasn't having it so she bought a
grooming kit on Amazon that Clippers
yeah and proceeded to begin to shorn our
dog and let me just say I'm I think it's
worth paying the groomers to get your
dog groomed based on what Barbara came
out looking like there was just
something I want to see what she looks
like well it it was really it only
lasted for about 48 hours it's like now
you can't really tell but it wasn't that
sure she did she did something with the
like the groomers they know about
balance right so you got like she's got
these furry legs and they're kind of
supposed to sort of maintain their width
as they go down and then maybe even
flare out a little bit the end it kind
of gives a dog sort of like it looks
like they got sort of a
these are things you don't ever think
about until you do it wrong so Jesse
went with like a tapered Jean look Oh
like an 80s tapered Jean look she's
clean Jessie it's like okay she got the
pain pants
it gave Barbara like a top heaviness it
looked like she's about to heat up over
at any time yeah and I was like how's
this dog even standing up straight and
it's a hair birds fruit I also realized
how shallow I am because I didn't like
Barbara for about 48 hours I was like
you're not she never reason I like you
is because you're a man now and also in
the back of my mind yes she's not she's
not getting on top of me in the morning
anymore so chicken in the egg oh but one
of the things that we thought about it
at a time when the grooming was
happening like I think there's something
with the anal gland I know they do
something with the anal gland but I mean
of course we're not gonna do that
they expresses that's what they do press
it and I was like well of course we're
not gonna we're not gonna go there but
the other night we're all watching
television together and Barbara comes in
the room and we immediately notice the
smell of it's like somebody took one of
those bottles of fish oil that you
vitamin you know take take for your
cardiovascular system and they left it
out in the Sun for like 72 months and
then they brought it inside and then
they opened it up that's what it's and I
and I figured that that wasn't what had
happened and so I just said is that the
anal gland it is yes and then Jesse
proceeded to grab Barbara and just
lightly lift her tail for a moment and
she confirmed it was indeed a anal gland
now typically they'll they'll they'll do
the butt scoot and that's also a sign
that the anal glands are not properly
expressing yeah well in looking after
I'm on YouTube YouTube is started
looking into this small dogs especially
our dogs are not natural our dogs are so
far from the distal canine species by
this point that there it comes with some
complications including they need humans
there to do things like express their
anal glands yeah on a regular basis in a
way that large dogs apparently don't
need as much and so I yeah because
typically in the wild because I've I was
curious about this like but a year ago
and because I never took Jade to the
groomer and I was and that helped me
justify doing it because I wasn't I was
curious but I didn't want to like put my
fingers where my research was you know
what I'm saying but I found out that
like not to get graphic but when a when
a when a dog that's functioning properly
poops it expresses the anal gland is
like part of that and yes so the poop
will stink even more and I don't I don't
know I don't care to know exactly why
this probably has to do is some sort of
like a Rommel communication but it's a
pourraient to me so I'm done talking
about it because I'm not cuz I finished
um so I watched I watched the YouTube
video and it was it looks so easy the
woman was like get a pair of gloves and
just sort of you know you sort of just
put your fingers on each side of the
anus and you squeeze and pull at the
same time and a clock initial she showed
I think it's more like three o'clock and
9 o'clock but she said this is what she
was like she showed on like a paper
towel or something like this is what
will come out and it will smell awful uh
and so we gave Barbara a bat a bath and
I proceeded to put on the only gloves I
had which were dish gloves I reached in
there Barbara seemed to look before you
gave her a bath or after uh no before
okay good like during yeah yeah she was
at she was in the sink getting ready to
get what Barbara looked at me like well
now well yeah your pinch this is Venus
and but she also didn't seem to mind too
much which I guess it was like oh you
also do this I've had this done
regularly by that lady at the groomer
but that's okay lots of new things
happening from
illegal nothing can't nothing came out
and I think that what we concluded at
the time was well she must have already
expressed herself yeah you know earlier
that's what happened we were watching
television now
I said I'm not going to talk about just
to interject my experience here I was
experiencing the same Jade was doing the
scooting I gave her a bath a week ago
and I remembered as I was giving her a
bath
she's been scooting I need to I need to
try this and it just so happens you need
to try scooting Eric the guy who used to
be our friend who then we fell out of
contact with and then he started texting
us about our lost year's podcast after
that he sent me a text and he was like
this is what I'm doing today or
something and then it was a like a
wikiHow picture of expressing a dog's
anal glance everybody's having to figure
this out and that image popped into my
head and I thought it was ten and two
but that's when your driver's ed and you
know what I just reached under there and
I gave it a little pinch and I didn't
even have on gloves oh god what why
because at some times my Nana comes out
in me and my Nana
you know my Nana she's like she
sometimes she doesn't care like she'll
walk around naked or she'll like she'll
do to walk in farts and she doesn't
apologize for anything she'll teach you
know when she taught me how to blow what
does it have to do about dogs but she um
poked her tongue through it and then
take it out of her mouth and then put
that slot where her tongue was over my
tongue and and tell me to blow and
that's how I learned to blow bubbles she
was she's grew up on the farm she
doesn't care about stuff like this you
touch it touch a dog's anus and then
you're watching the dog just immediately
wash your hand and that I just did that
and I know that seems out of character
for me but I'm like screw it
we're in wash mode let's go for it what
up but did anything come out I couldn't
tell no I'm sure I could tell in that
YouTube video and I couldn't tip but so
nothing came out with Barbara but then
literally as we were getting ready to
record this thirty seconds before we
press record jesse was standing right
over here and said yeah I'm smelling it
again
so I think the fact if you can smell it
it's a problem and I think I'm gonna
have to go in again you're gonna have to
go in deeper it's it you need a deeper
pinch and don't wear gloves you really
need to you really need to bond with
your dog what is wrong with you anyway
so that's you know relationships are
changing yeah
conventions are changing I mean if I can
figure out how to do this are we gonna
take you know our groomers gonna go out
of business
my groomers not gonna go out of business
because this isn't something I want to
make a regular thing this is something I
want to do only in times of desperation
it might be like a dr. pimple popper
thing you might experience some pleasure
associated with a victory with success
don't don't count your chickens before
the can opens you might like English
okay we're gonna talk more about
relational dynamics and I don't think
we're gonna talk anymore about anuses
dogs or otherwise but first we're gonna
talk about these mugs mythical calm is
the source for everything you need to
express your personal mythicality I mean
we ever do not use the term Express oh
just don't use the term Express I feel
like we look at our mugs don't think
about Uranus you know we're connecting
through this conversation I feel like
you're a part of it even though you're
pretty quiet and you feel even more part
of it if you were drinking tea or coffee
or any beverage you want it could be
like anal granik's collisions for all I
care no grand exclusion that's a great
band name
that's how locked ain't no brand is at
Optics collisions exclusion he would
change words like that right yeah he
still does from the time mythical car
yeah yeah get your mugs
connect with us make it a complete
embodiment experience wear the shirts
wear the necklace is where the perfumes
wear everything we sell and then sip
from the things we sell okay before we
dive into this I will say we're going to
be talking about
this from the from the standpoint of
people who are in a family and trapped
with them and I know that there are a
lot of single people who have maybe the
opposite problem which is no one to
connect with and so there's I think
there's a loneliness that's not
something that we can speak to
personally at this point but I do want
to recognize there are a lot of people
in that particular situation I'm glad
you're bringing that up yeah because I
think there's gonna be there's gonna be
some some complaining coming from us and
I don't know maybe if you if you're in a
different situation maybe it'll be
helpful for for for them to hear how
it's not it's not that great for us at
times either but we do it is a good
acknowledgement and we we feel for you
if you're if you feel isolated or lonely
and we want to encourage you to do
whatever you can to to break out of that
and I know I can imagine that might be
difficult at times to like to pick up
the video chat and to initiate I don't
know and maybe more for guys to say hey
I'm you mean I'm just facetiming you
because I feel lonely you know it's not
the type of thing that what I I didn't
feel like that was the thing as a guy
that I would give myself permission to
say years back yeah good so I found a
couple of articles that I think speak to
this I you know one of the things that's
happening of course is couples who did
not who have never spent this much time
together are now spending this much time
together yeah and the question is what
is that gonna do for relationships what
is that doing for families I mean when
you think about our situation which i
think is probably a pretty typical
situation in in the world and in America
is that a lot of dads are spending a lot
more time at home than they normally
would
and and this is the company this time it
isn't just dad's it's working moms
yeah working moms any any of anybody who
is spent a lot of time
traditionally outside of the house is
suddenly there and it's like one of
those if you think about when you go on
vacation and we've talked about this
dynamic before when you go on vacation
even with the distractions of vacation
being in a foreign land of some kind
yeah having a schedule having a pool
that you could lounge next to and stuff
like that
even with all those amenities still by
the end of a week-long vacation most
people are like I gotta get away from my
family yeah you know yeah but we're all
on extended vacations of indefinite
length and we don't have we actually
have the most familiar surroundings and
we don't have an option to really
experience in or most of our
neighborhoods are becoming much more
familiar I mean we've walked I could
draw you a map
of my neighborhood at this point and
doesn't actually sound impressive but ok
I couldn't draw a map of your
neighborhood before this ok no judgment
no I mean have you been my
neighborhood's got a lot of weird
streets and they're not there's no
system it's not a grid and so I'm just
saying that now I feel like I've been on
streets that are less than a mile away
that was like never been on this street
never been on this street I've been on
all the streets now multiple times but
I'm just saying that the level of
familiarity with our family and our
surroundings is it an all-time high oh
and it's creating some different
dynamics there's an article in the well
could I've seen a few articles that
talked about like what's gonna happen is
there gonna be a corona virus baby boom
because all these couples are at home
together and everybody's having sex like
it's just I know how babies are made and
then the other theory is well actually
there's gonna be a boom and divorces I
think most likely you're gonna see both
of those things happening hopefully not
in the same families together at the
same time oh hey there
opening his elevator you think there was
the honeymoon phase of quarantine that
was like hey listen let's sort the mail
this'll be fun right and then a few
weeks later it's like what I checked the
mailbox and I walked straight from the
mailbox to the recycle bin because
everything that was sent was junk for
those of you who may be confused or
maybe you're a new listener to your
biscuits don't explain it I think I have
to explain it because I care about those
people sorting the mail is a euphemism
only on this podcast for sexual
intercourse I know how big don't eat
maid don't ask us how that happened but
it did give me one article bedroom
ironically this is an article in the New
York Post which is not typically a
publication that I frequent but they had
an article about the surge in divorces
cooped-up New Yorkers are flooding
lawyer phone lines with divorce
enquiries with an avalanche of filings
expected once the courts reopen people
are realizing that they can't stand each
other said Manhattan lawyer Susan
Kimberly Bracker who like many in her
field has already seen a coronavirus
divorce uptick in the middle of the
night I got a call from a client who now
realizes she has nothing in common with
her husband but the children and how he
knows nothing about the children it's
like and and this is something that
again this is sort of a stereotypical
trophy thing but you got the dude who's
been off at the jaw his job and then he
comes back home and he is like oh now
I've got to do something I've got to
engage with the kids more than just like
hey I'm home dad's home let's shoot some
basketball for 30 minutes and that makes
me a great dad but you know saying is
like now you're kind of expected and a
lot of people are are continuing to
do their jobs from home which can be a
little bit disruptive I mean even right
now I'm we're sitting here in the middle
of our homes making everybody else be
relatively quiet while we do this yeah
typically Lily will will roll out of bed
and she'll walk in here and she'll see
me doing this and then she will just
like slump over roll our eyes go back
into her bedroom because she realized
that she can't make breakfast because it
makes too much noise and I told her she
could tiptoe around and make the
breakfast but you know what she's she's
being ultra ultra sensitive I mean not
sensitive but considerate and she's not
doing it
but it's like yeah so our work lives
coming home is a severe inconvenience to
our families you're in the freakin
middle of your living room if somebody
wanted to watch TV this morning that
ain't happening to their televisions
well it wouldn't be on the big one on
your left
exactly yeah in in one of the things
that's happening too is I think that a
lot of people are seeing their working
parent or their working spouse in work
mode in a way that they haven't this
article from The Washington Post this
woman Lauren Orkin deputy editor of
InStyle magazine
tweeted a funny thing about quarantine
is hearing your partner in full work
mode for the first time like I'm married
to a let's circle back guy who knew I've
never heard somebody use that if you
take this offline and then circle back
on it later and then we can close the
loop when we've taken the pin out of it
but for now we're putting the pin in it
put a pin I will say there there are
some positives from this so as you know
we have our company-wide meeting and
there's not really a place in my house
to get away even when you go into the
most private of places which would be
our guest bedroom yeah the crack under
the door is like an inch so you can hear
anything everything is happening in
there and Jesse was working outside on
her computer right outside the room yeah
and we had our meeting you know
we're having every two weeks where
everybody it mythical gets on a video
chat and we talk about business and also
just kind of connect with one another
and she I come out of the door and she
was like you sound like a good boss
sound like a boss
you sound like a nice nice boss she's
surprised I was like oh thank you I
think she I think that she knows that
I'm not you know neither of us are those
typical like chew your head off bosses
that's just not in our character
disposition but I think I think
listening in on the meeting and like
again just hearing my side of it so she
didn't she didn't come out I didn't come
out and she said oh you're a circle bad
guy she's like oh you're a nice boss I
was like well good yeah I'm gonna get a
mug that says I'm a nice boss as I'm
setting things up for good mother good
morning or for for this show like I
noticed Chris he was on his beat should
like look at me and like she's like a
sesame she's I even even just right
before we started recording she like
comes right over the camera she's like
pokes her head around for the kid she's
like are you okay now that's a there's a
little more to it you get into a little
bit but I'm like I'm fine she was like
you look pale I'm like what I'm thinking
is I get stressed out right before I do
something especially when there's all
these people and groceries came in this
morning again go good law oh yeah I'm
like yeah I'm pale I get pale before I
start anything cuz I'm freaking I'm
stressed spiking and then I get my robe
on and I sit down I'm like alright
alright and then I I'm mellow out a
little bit and I get in the zone the
AutoZone but like she's like not a
sponsor you are so worked up I'm like
yeah I get worked up that's why it's
called work I get up for it I so i
didn't get it you're a good boss but
she's not listening in on our oh I've
got another that hands meeting as we
used to call it at IBM now before we but
before we kind of before this takes a
trip
to the dark side I do I'm gonna talk
about a lot of the positives because I
think that this has been a really
positive time for our family in a lot of
ways I made a little list here so I
wouldn't forget now Jesse and I had a
date night before where we would go out
once a week but we're continuing to do
that you know date night is our takeout
night where we we get some takeout and
we send the children away they can be
anywhere but anywhere near us and you
know we put on some music change the
lighting a little bit and I still in the
kitchen talking about the bedroom yet
and that's where mail happening and you
know he's have a nice dinner and we act
we talk about the the nature of our
relationship actually talk about how we
talk you know I think that's been good
we got our family movie night that we do
every Friday night where we all sit down
and try to agree on a movie which has
been going pretty well really watch
tombstone the other night that was a hit
Val County listen it's one of the best
ever Kurt Russell a little uneven acting
in that movie but he's Kurt Russell
we're also like you were watching
Survivor that's something the family is
connected on lock and I have our horror
movie night on Saturday nights Sheppard
and I are starting an art project based
on the golden ratio Fibonacci numbers
and we are playing horse and having
putting contests and there's a lot of
like family interaction that's happening
at a higher volume that has been great
but of course with all that interaction
with the good comes the bad yeah we've
had I mean you know how the Neil's are
we like to stay hydrated and when we go
in on something we go in deep we go in
hard boy that sounded weird we really we
fully commit to something and there's a
there's a dark side to that like we
started watching Survivor and like as
we've discussed before we start at
season 17 because I knew that I knew if
everyone got hooked on him we got
aligned on this thing we needed a whole
bunch of seasons to just start binging
through because we wouldn't want we just
want to keep going down that rabbit hole
so now we're over halfway through season
18 and basic everybody's so excited
about it it aligns us it's a it's a
beautiful thing
it's kind of magical that everyone loves
it and it's the lately it's the only
thing we've been willing to do together
like there's so here I am already going
to the dark side like I mean yesterday
I'm freaking I'm Phil we're doing an AMA
for the for the mythical society peeps
and I guess to them it just looks like
I'm typing on my computer doesn't I'm
not filming anything and they're outside
they're outside in the garage playing
ping pong which that's another thing
that we that we do but now that's become
a source of contention well I didn't
finish the survivor thought the thought
is survivors the only thing that we keep
that we end up doing every single night
so we don't have enough variety and it's
like what's a survivor every night every
single night and it's too much it's a
problem yeah and then you know we're not
having enough other positive Alice as a
family so I'm doing the AMA and they're
outside playing ping pong and then this
is not the first nor the second time
this has happened in the past three days
but all of a sudden I hear I hear Lando
screaming and a lot of times when he's
screaming he's screaming delete it
delete it Joe what didn't eat it and he
comes in here and he's where he runs to
me he's like dad Lincoln took video of
me and he won't delete it and like
what's he gonna do is he gonna post it
online he's like he might I was like has
he ever done that then Lincoln walks in
and he has this like Lincoln grin on his
face
he thinks that he is enjoying this
moment this is what he's doing it for to
me ride him crazy you would you would
have thought
Lincoln filmed Lando confessing to a
murder you know it's like that that's
the level of intensity and then the more
that Lincoln just kind of grins at him
the more he just goes ballistic and I
get to a point where I'm like in that
three hours later I'm getting red I'm
queueing up survivor okay finally we can
have our positive time together we can
agree on this we can at least all be in
the same room but not at each other's
throats and I'm like they kept I
wouldn't come and they wouldn't come so
I've got this technique where I start
playing survivor really loud and then
they'll like stop what they're doing and
they'll all run and they'll get off the
phones or whatever and run in well this
time instead of that happening it was
delete it and they ran in and you know
what without thinking about it I was
like you to go back out of the room and
handle it and then they stood there kind
of like bumfuzzled and I was like
go-gurt
and I looked at Christy who I was
talking with before they came in and she
was like she had this disappointed look
on her face at me yeah yeah and then the
boys left and I'm like what were you
saying you know it's like at a certain
point the but if the buttons been pushed
so much that is it won't pop back up you
know that you know that type of button
where it's like it gets pushed in and
then he gets lodged underneath something
so it's like or you think that the
button popped back up but really it like
you push it and instead of it popping
back up you push it and then you watch
it yeah I don't think a bunch come in
then all of a sudden it starts to come
back up a little bit and then stop that
happens with literally every keyboard
that we put in our kitchen because
jamming or how many times I tell my kids
to why
their hands before they type they don't
they won't so we go through like one
Apple magic keyboard every seven months
you talk about being being a good lawyer
in my budget and the way that we talk to
our employees sometimes it's like it
gets familial there's a good level of
family atmosphere and team atmosphere
but if I talk man I'm just being honest
you'd be shocked if you saw yeah you
know some of the things that come that
Ike sued especially in this okay I ended
in to support you and I've already said
that I mean first use to my kids but
that was a joke well but in terms of the
losing it and yelling that and first of
all there's people who are in families
where that doesn't ever happen right and
great it's great it's great for you and
also you may be shocked when you hear oh
you guys yeah you got yell at your
children cuz I I know I know that my
kids have friends whose parents never
yell at them and that's just not that's
not our family I'm not proud of it it's
just it's the way that it's kind of the
way that we are and like Jesse will be
working with Shepherd kind of getting
him to do now again she's home-schooled
the kids forever and they've only been
at school for like three years or now so
but of course she thought she was done
and this and now everybody's
homeschooling right and are doing the
distance learning thing but with
Shepherd especially that does that
doesn't mean that he's just gonna do it
do the work you gotta stay with him and
make him do the work keep him from being
distracted and Jesse is more patient
than me and tries to engage with him at
a fruitful way yeah we've been we've
both married much better people than we
are and that's a wonderful yeah and for
us and it and then she will but then you
know I'll come out of a meeting or
podcast or whatever happened
doing and she'll say your turn when this
is not something that happens when I'm
at work but when I'm at home working it
does happen on a regular basis and then
I'll go in there and I'll kind of enter
into the situation with Shepherd with
some patients at the beginning that is
exhausted is I think my patients tank
needs to be repaired it has several
leaks and as soon as I fill it up
Shepherd finds a way to like pull the
pull the plugs out and I'm I'm I'm
basically I've gone from trying to work
with him to just telling him just
basically shaming him right that's
ultimately what yelling at somebody does
is it you try you're trying to use shame
to get them to do it and I know it's not
effective when when I'm doing I know
it's not effective but that's what I end
up resorting to in my very quickly and
you ending in your tank gets smaller and
smaller smaller the more time that you
spend together in my mind I'm thinking
and I did once once I did tell Christy
at that point I was like I figured this
is worth a shot
after I said just resolve it yourself
handle it and they left the room and I
was like what are we talking about then
I was like getting I I yelled
in a calculated way because I want
because I we don't yell that often I
mean it's not something I mean there are
family cultures we're like little
subcultures of families where they were
they'll yell more and it's just like
everybody's got a thick skin when it
comes to that and it's a it's a form of
communication and everybody everybody
knows how to handle it and it's in it I
don't think it's absolutely a horrible
thing to raise your voice I think that
there are I would imagine that there's
home climates where it it can just be
you can be expressive but but it's it
very quickly goes to a danger zone and
that's that that's what we feel in our
house and so the goal is you know to
always remaining
controla not to raise your voice I mean
we all agree on that over here and
that's that's I wouldn't put that
standard on anybody else cuz I'm not a
I'm not a psychologist but for me that's
that's what we've landed so it does
immediately feel like a failure when I
do yell and but I thought it was worth a
shot for me to say this was a calculated
yell for me to express how much of an
impact this ongoing quarrel has on me
sigh Oh dad must feel strongly about
this this is impacting him I mean it
wasn't that compelling of an argument
but I tried to work no it wasn't that
Christie was mad at me I mean we just
you know she helped me talk through it
and then like I was like no did did did
they cut did they resolve their conflict
and come back in yeah well I didn't hear
it anymore
they shut up which again that was my
goal it was like stop impacting my
quality of life it was that selfish
stance of I don't care as long as you
guys can shut up somewhere else and I
don't hear it I will be fine but then
later on we called him back in there and
we had a we had a 10 minute discussion
that was more like hey how do we get how
do we get to the bottom of this now in
retrospect I might could have added an
apology about like losing my losing my
cool and raising my voice and especially
when you make the point about shaming
because I think that's a good point
maybe I'll revisit that but we at least
had a constructive conversation about
how they can own what they're doing and
what their motives are and because
Lincoln's doing it on purpose and now
Lando's developing this coping mechanism
of yelling at him this is a new thing so
it's like trying to get to the bottom of
that but I mean the end this came at the
end of a long day I mean at the
beginning of the day we're in a
different way than Shepherd but we're
having we're just trying to get Lincoln
to be more motivated to the schoolwork
it's very difficult to
- to do schoolwork in this environment
and he he comes in this morning he's
like mom dad I've done some research and
I'm like I perk up I'm like my boys done
research this is great I immediately
felt proud I was like I've never heard
him use that phrase before I've done
some research and he says the LA Unified
School District says that the grades
that you have when you left for a
quarantine they can't make your grade
lower than that
so I'm not gonna do any more school work
I was like well this took a turn and
then Christy was like who told you this
oh that's of high school rumor well my
friends my friends aren't doing their
work cuz they they said that's true and
then she's like first of all we're not
in the LA Unified School District and so
that so we I mean we on and off all day
we were kind of bantering getting into
that and then Lando and him are at each
other's throats because I won't let him
be on screens all day and I forced him
to go outside and play together and then
they come in at each other's throats and
you know Lily had her own you know I'm
not gonna tell Lily's story on here but
there was something that Lily suffered a
disappointment like there was so she got
some disappointing news something she
was looking forward to it went the other
way and this was like months of looking
forward to getting this news and so it
was kind of it was a bit shattering for
for Chrissy and I as well as for her you
know so it's like that was also
yesterday so it's you know you you have
these ideas that like things are you
know and on previous podcast we we
talked about this mindset of like seeing
things as an opportunity and
not being Pollyanna about how things are
going in the world or even in our homes
but feeling like okay you know what we
can find the silver lining we can we can
see the opportunities in this we can
like the things that you listed out and
then knowing at the end of this that
we're going to see it as a precious time
because we do love each other and thank
goodness we we care about each other and
we're not you know there's a lot of
people who a don't have anybody or they
they're like on the they're on the outs
of a relationship or they were about to
break it up or like good there's lots of
more nightmare situations than the ones
we were in we've got it really great
with our families but it just gets to
you man you know well and I think that
it's I mean I do think it's important to
recognize that because I think you could
say something and I'm sure someone has
written something like this where it's
like it's not that being cooped up in
your home is going to cause a divorce
it's that being cooped up in your home
is going to reveal the reality of how
you actually whether or not you actually
connect that's the kind of BS that
somebody would say because the fact is
is that regardless of the nature of your
relationship regardless of how healthy
it is this is going to be difficult for
almost everyone and that doesn't mean
that you should break up you should get
a divorce or you're not compatible now
there could that doesn't also doesn't
mean that you know there will be some
real discovery and real discussion
during this time that you realize that
you got some things to work on or maybe
you do realize that you've come to an
impasse that you can't get through but I
think it's helpful to hear that it's a
it's incredibly normal to respond to
this situation in a negative way and
have to resist you know being selfish
and being self-interested and
and and I also think that there is some
depending on your personality I mean for
me as an introvert it's like it's not a
negative thing when I think I gotta get
away from these people that doesn't make
me a bad person it doesn't make them bad
people it just means that the register
needs to eject himself from this
situation right and go on a solo walk in
fact Jesse now we're talking about this
yesterday because Jesse is a one of the
biggest differences between the two of
us we have so many things in common we
enjoy so many things we connect in a lot
of different ways but she is a hyper
extrovert and I'm in it I'm not a hyper
introvert I kind of present as an
extrovert to most people who get to know
me for the first time but in reality I'm
energized by being alone so I'm an
introvert but so when I talk about
things like I'm gonna go work out she's
like first week she was like you want to
work out together and I'm like no I
don't want to work out together for like
seven reasons the least of which being
that we're not gonna do the same stuff
in a workout but the main reason being
that this it it's a time for me like I
put on I listen to a book you know I
don't I don't listen to light pump up
music when I work out I listen to books
on tape right and when I walk around the
neighborhood by myself I listen I listen
as well it's like you got a taper got
you got a Walkman and take a cassette
tape I just have a you know I've just
got your phones and and I thought but
yeah it's your time and you need you
need the nineteen RG well and even it's
a day or yesterday when you know our
days right now or consist of doing
something in the morning and something
in the afternoon this work-related
typically right every weekday and even
something as simple as like okay let's
record two episodes of good mythical
morning today like there's been some
days where we've recorded one in the
morning and one of the evening or one in
the afternoon and you would think oh two
episodes of GMM like that's what else
you got going on that's an easy day but
the setup and then the getting it all
right and then the meeting before and
then you having
into taking the thumbnails and then
uploading the footage before you know it
you've taken all day to shoot two
episodes of GMM and that is not mom's
act right exactly but I had like a
little window in between the other day
and I said I'm gonna take a walk by
myself
if sunny outside I was like I'm gonna
take a walk by myself and then Jesse
said okay and then she told me this
morning she was like when you said that
because we were talking about this
dynamic before it recorded this she said
you know my instinct is to be like well
I want to go on a walk with you like you
were gonna go on a walk let's go
together but she is like no I stopped
and realized that know that debts that's
what he that's what he needs that's good
for him and it's not he's not saying
anything about me like she was like
that's not say anything about her that I
need to get away from her it doesn't
isn't saying more about me yeah it
reminds me the same principle but
Christie made a comment to me at the at
the end of the night last night after we
had gotten through survivor and then I
think there was I there was still I said
something sarcastic while everyone was
going off to bed and she said you know I
think the only person that doesn't annoy
you is you she said and then she turned
into the whole family she's like you
know what I think your dad might need to
let like to camp in the backyard he
might need to do a little like camping
time by himself I'm like all right first
of all all right tit for tat I was
sarcastic so I message received and I
laughed and you know it - it broke the
tension you know it didn't it didn't
escalate it da she knew how to she was
doing that to deescalate and it worked
but um yeah I I think we're I think that
was her observation we're coming to
grips with that - that like I mean I'm
I've been getting up an hour or an hour
and a half before everybody else and
I've been I've been meditating
I mean I'm today was 30 days in a row
I've meditated well yes that's like it
that that it keeps a record of it on the
app so it motivates me to do it like I
said but I don't know it's not enough I
don't know it's like I'm I still suck at
meditating by the way so I'm not
bragging it's just like I think I am
getting insights but insights into
myself and and how to how to cope but
I'm not quite engaging those lessons
enough but you know I the other thing I
haven't mentioned yet as far as relating
to Christy goes I think it's been a real
challenge and you know this that
Chrissy's been sick for over two weeks
and it was a it was just a mild fever
every day for the past over two weeks
that hasn't broken a hundred but when
it's like that for days and days and
days and weeks you know she's been in
conversation with her doctor and there's
been like stomach issues some loss of
appetite so she's lost over ten pounds
because she hasn't been able to eat and
like with diarrhea and then but those
are the only symptoms so the doctor was
saying well that's you know there's
covetous it was weird and it's it
manifests in different ways of different
people but they didn't think that's what
it was but then finally after a week and
a half I took her to get the test like a
drive-through test and I gotta say I got
a thrill out of her taking the test
because you know that it's like a big
nice like a you say cleaner it's like a
freaking pipe cleaner that's like that
long and then they they said when you
draw it you'll drive up and you can stay
in your car and we'll do the throat swab
and so Christy was thinking it was a
throat swab but the way they access
throat is through the nose and so I knew
this she didn't know it so and I didn't
know for sure she didn't know it until I
saw the look on her face as it started
to happen the dude reaches and he's like
now I'm gonna count five seconds it's
gonna feel a lot longer than five
seconds but I'm just gonna count and
then she they the guy took the pipe
cleaner put it in her nose her eyes got
huge her feet started beating the
floorboard of the car and she said that
it went all that she said if I were to
open my mouth and looked at you you
would have seen the thing go go past my
throat that down there and start and
then he's he's he's counting to five and
he's twisting it yeah and then he's
pulling it out yeah I'm sorry I thought
I got a key I got a kick out of her
beads so surprised not because it hurt
because it was unkind I wouldn't say it
hurt it did hurt but it was what it's
just like when it's well you you've
experienced we both have experienced it
because yeah when you got your we went
to the plastic surgeon to do the
commercial and he showed you how to look
down at your throat but they did the
same thing to me at the ENT when I was
having some sort of issues a couple
years ago and it's like again goes
through the nose and I have a deviated
septum in my right nostril like you
can't eat you can't get in there and the
left nostril is open but prone to
bleeding so it's like I just I don't
want to have to get tested I hope they
come up with I want one of the less
invasive ones two days later we got the
results back and they were negative she
was still having the symptoms and I mean
she started to develop pain in her chest
like I was like oh I think I'm having
trouble breathing and I was she had had
a that similar symptom earlier in the
year and she got checked out for that
and we thought there might be something
there might be a heart thing or
something she got all checked out she
was fine we realized that like anxiety
was driving a lot of her symptoms at the
time and then I was making the point
that those I think anxiety might be
manifesting this in
now because even though your test was
negative the doctor did happen to
mention that it's possible to have a
false negative that she could have covet
but that and they said if you start to
have breathing problems you need to call
us and then we might need to take
decisive action and then I observed that
she started to say that she was having
breathing problems she woke up in the
middle of the night I woke up three
nights ago at like 3:30 in the morning
and she was having a panic attack but
she didn't know if she just couldn't
breathe and it's it was I don't I don't
I mean I was kind of groggy I'm not the
most supportive at 4 a.m. I was you know
but I was I was trying to be supportive
but I mean ultimately she yesterday she
went in for a lung x-ray just to so the
doctor could make sure she didn't have
it we didn't go to the emergency room
that night I kind of talked her down and
helped her calm down but then the next
morning which was yesterday she went in
the the test results for that were
totally clear her lungs are totally fine
which is more support that you know this
is I don't know if I would say
psychosomatic maybe that is the right
term but it's caused by her heightened
anxiety associated with you know being
in this pandemic where here's the
connection for her you know over three
years ago and she's told this story on
science Mike's science Mike's podcast
about how she you know she hit her head
she's getting she had the concussion she
still suffers from post concussion
syndrome but the thing that I think
we're coming to grips with is that
because of that she's suffering from
PTSD she now on a subconscious level
believes that if something so as if the
odds are so low for something like her
hitting her head on a limb walking into
the Trader Joe's
can then three years later have a
dramatic and drastic impact on her life
then well when this virus starts
sweeping through town she's gonna get it
you know she just knows it you know on a
like that's what that's the survival
technique that that I think she's
learned and again I mean so you know
it's it's been difficult you know with a
couple of days of a flare-up of symptoms
and anxiety like we can work together
but like when it when it's like over two
weeks I mean it's it starts to become
very difficult to to be empathetic you
know because it's frustrating it's very
frustrating for me too
because I feel like I don't have the
magic words to get through to her or I
don't have the techniques to fix her and
she's not asking for that from me
and you know she's asking for an open
ear and she's asking for I think she
wants she wants empathy and she just
wants me to be there for her as she goes
through this and be supportive because
she does have a therapist she does have
a brain doctor she does have a normal
doctor she has and she has other friends
that provide a support structure too so
it's like she doesn't need everything
from me I don't need to be the Silver
Bullet
but it's it again it when everyday it
gets increasingly more difficult
especially when I see that her symptoms
are getting better except for the
anxiety you know so it's and she gave me
permission to talk about this by the way
but she was like what are you gonna talk
about in your biscuits I was like we're
gonna talk about relational dynamics she
was like you know you can you didn't
talk about this because and I applaud
her for it that like the things that I'm
sharing are not things to be embarrassed
about
there are actual conditions that people
suffer from whether it's depression
anxiety post concussion syndrome all
types of silent illnesses you know I
think she encouraged me to share this
story because just to remove that stigma
but you know well and I can I can speak
on behalf of hypochondriacs everywhere
which I think people who would relate to
and I talked to my dad who my dad is
like me and presents himself as
invincible but it's like okay
the very first so I went a long time in
my life without thinking that not
believing like I refused to believe that
you could feel something physical in
your body and it not be real like but in
the past 10 years I have felt so many
specific things injuries and sicknesses
and and and and then it turns out to not
be anything and it's begin and so with a
coronavirus the first week that we were
home I swear to you because I was
consuming so much news I had pain I had
legitimate pain in my chest and I kept
telling Jessie I was like I think I got
it I was like I don't have any other
symptoms but like when I breathe in like
he hurt my chest hurts I was like
literally I can point to it it's hurting
right here and it's hurting right here
and I was like and it comes and it goes
and I've had it for a week and then I
talked to my dad anyway and he was like
I've had coronavirus 20 times since this
whole thing started like he he was he
was like it's just in our genes to for
it to manifest itself in that way so I
mean I it doesn't mean you're crazy it's
I think it's very normal and you can
actually and I've had a kind of I don't
plan I'm not crazy you're saying it
doesn't mean that my wife is crazy right
yeah yeah yeah yeah there's a couple
alike in that whole feeling like you
can't breathe thing and like there's a
couple times in the past few weeks I've
woken up with a mellow night and I've
been like I think I'm Shh
I think I'm not getting a full breath
the the moment that you think that it's
very difficult to get out of it
it's very difficult to get out of it and
it's and again I'm not and I'm not
telling people that they should ignore
their symptoms I I do think that for me
a lot of times doing what Christie did
and like going and getting the x-ray so
you can be told definitively sometimes
you do need that you need that like oh
no this there's nothing there's actually
nothing wrong with you
because hypochondriacs like me will keep
thinking like yeah you're just telling
me there's nothing wrong with me but in
reality there is and you just don't want
me to think about it you know and
sometimes you do have to go to that
place it can't get to a place where
you're you're having to have all these
things confirmed all the time but I just
say that as somebody who hasn't had
nearly the issue you know the struggle
that Christie has had and I haven't had
the post concussion syndrome or anything
like that but I am a hypochondriac and I
have thought that I had coronavirus
already and it's very sure of it it's
just so difficult to be empathetic
because I'm not great at it in general
but then and I I think when we were
talking out our highlights from the year
I might have talked about the dynamic of
I end up I'm not sure but I'll whenever
she says I'm concerned about this
whether it's a physical symptoms related
to this or it's related to the kids or
something else whenever she says she
expresses anxiety towards something my
need recreation without actually hearing
her is to just minimize or try to make
it disappear entirely like to dismiss
her her instincts you know or her her
concerns and you know I told her it's
like you know at a certain point if
something's really concerned she'll be
like you don't seem concerned at all and
I'm like one thing I was like you know
you cry if you cry wolf too many times
then the the the farmers not gonna come
or I don't know how the story goes and
that was not that was not a sensitive
thing to say but it was an honest thing
that like it's it is a struggle to
continue to hear her and to to empathize
with her when I it's so foreign to my
own experience that like I you know I
think I live with my I'm I live with my
head in the clouds sometimes maybe it's
how I think how she feels about me
because we are experience is so
different in this way and it's so it's
in this but it's very frustrating to not
to be able to fix it and then tuna and
then whenever I start to say well that's
not what I need to do I just need to be
there then it's like it's hard to access
the the energy to because it's against
my instincts to interact with her in
that way and so you know after over two
weeks of that it's like again that was
the that was the last thing over the
past two days that was like okay this is
this is difficult you know I just to
kind of just to kind of close the loop
on it what was the corporate saying
circle a circle but I don't want to have
to circle back on this later so let's
close the loop now you know it's a this
morning I took my meditative time to
kind of think more about about her and
about just to have an an exercise in
empathy and then afterward it you know
it gave me the capacity to to go
upstairs and to apologize for you know
how I've I wore my frustration on my
sleeve and there was no yelling with
Christy you know it wasn't like that
it was it was more of like this just
this just you could see you could just
sense the frustration and it in it
seemed like annoyance you know
but I think we were you know we about
have a good conversation this morning
and clear the era about that and you
know I know that she is she's pulling on
resources and seeing ways that she can
you know there's additional treatments
and therapies and things like that that
will help her through this that it's not
and and I can be I can be there to help
her help her wade through that stuff but
I mean I know she's in that process too
so we're not stuck and we're not and so
we had a moment we had a good moment
this morning where it was like kind of a
reconnection and just being honest and
so that's the just to close the loop on
that but well yeah I know it's a you
know given the there's a lot of things
about this particular situation and the
things that we continue to read about
the virus that make it very it's a
specifically difficult situation for
people who are hypochondriacs because
the virus the symptoms are so they don't
know anything about it it's like yeah
you you read that one article and it's
not okay well it seems that it presents
this way in most people but for some
people it's just like this and there's
some people all of a sudden they go to
state there's all these little things
that I think people who write these
articles and again they're not you know
when you're writing about it you don't
have hypochondriacs in mind and actually
hypochondriacs need to learn how to deal
with I say this as a hypochondriac you
need to be able to engage with
information in a way that doesn't
immediately make me think that I have it
but it's very difficult because it
manifests itself in so many different
ways and we've been told it's super
contagious and you're out of your normal
routine you got a lot of all a lot of us
are doing is just reading the news and
sitting around and thinking and it's
like that's good that could be a really
bad combination so I do I do think it's
important that in
again for the longest time I just
thought I thought that my mom was a
hypochondriac and I was like well that's
not me and then I and then I realized no
you know what actually you know I am and
now I'm talking to my dad I'm like oh I
also my dad is it's like we we we all
have this tendency to immediately kind
of internalize it so I just think that
it's okay it doesn't again it doesn't
make you Abdur Mille it's such a common
thing but it is important to realize it
and address it I mean with me I can
carapace I can talk to about it I think
that that continues to be really
important for a lot of people there are
resources if you you know there's mental
health resources that are available in
this very difficult time for a lot of
people and we just encourage you to
continue to to seek those out I mean not
a sponsor they were a sponsor at one
time but I know there's better help you
know which is like you basically have a
teleconference with somebody which is
what we're all doing with our therapist
right now anyway but there are there are
services like that we just encourage you
to if you feel like you need somebody to
talk to and you don't have somebody that
you can talk to who will listen and be
helpful and again like links talking
about it's like we're none of us are
trained in this and a lot of times don't
know what to say and we'll say the wrong
thing finding somebody who can actually
help you think through this and work
through this in a healthy way is
important yeah so and I yeah I'm it's
it's helpful to talk about it here I
think it's you know it's with Chrissy's
permission it's calculated to talk about
it here because I know a lot of people
like you said relate to it and yeah so
we're not you know we're not in the
business of providing answers but we're
in the business of just being an honest
and like sharing our journey so and it's
and it's helpful yourself holding me to
do that so I
appreciate opening the can of the can of
listen here is your wreck yeah so I'm
gonna wreck a book that I listen to
during my workouts and my strolls okay
and it's called Underland by Robert
McFarlane and I didn't know about this
Robert McFarlane guy I didn't know he's
a writer
from the UK who sort of specializes in
writing about nature so it's a nice
non-fiction but the way that he writes
about his experience specifically in
Underland which I've always you know I'm
fascinated with geology and also just
underground things in general but this
is this incredible multi-year journey
where he went underground basically into
like caves and mines and underground
systems under cities and met the people
who know about these places and visited
them himself and his way of kind of
bringing you along for the ride but it
it also becomes a story about the earth
in the environment and what's happening
in the world top ten favorite books of
all time what I mean it's not even this
is on fiction yeah and again this is not
this isn't for everybody
again if but if you happen to be
interested in that in the way that I
described that if that piques your
interest at all
there's nobody that I'm aware of who can
write in a more compelling way almost a
spiritual way there's like a spiritual
experience in the way that he kind of
approaches this stuff hmm that it's
again it's been super meditative to like
walk and listen to this these stories
about these people and it's sort of like
really tapped into my sense of adventure
which I kind of feel like I haven't
really been feeding for a long time we
do a lot
crazy things our lives are pretty we
could do a lot of amazing things but
just this guy's commitment to going out
into the world and then talking about it
in a compelling ways
so that's Underland okay yeah all one
word alright thanks for hanging out with
us this week we'll speak again next week
you know we love to watch more ear
biscuits click on the playlist on the
right to watch the previous episode of
your biscuits click on the playlist to
the left and don't forget to click on
the circular icon to subscribe if you
prefer to listen to this podcast it's
available on all your favorite podcast
platforms thanks for being your mythical
best
[Music]